WALLS, MAKE A GRIEVOUS ERROR.
>> Tucker: THERE IS NOTHING
THE MEDIA WON'T REPEAT NODDING
MINDLESSLY.
HERE'S ANOTHER THING CNN
DEMOCRATS AGREE ON, THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER IS A BRAVE HERO
DOING A VITAL SERVICE TO THIS
COUNTRY.
HE'S A WHISTLE-BLOWER!
THE FUNNY THING IS AND YOU LIVE
IN WASHINGTON, WE HAVE
WHISTLE-BLOWERS HERE AND THEY
ARE ALMOST ALWAYS IGNORED AND
MISTREATED BY THE PEOPLE IN
POWER.
ALL THE COOL KIDS LOOKED DOWN ON
REAL WHISTLE-BLOWERS.
IT'S AMAZING.
MOST OF THEM YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW
EXIST.
YOU NEVER HEAR THEIR NAMES.
ONE EXEMPTION TO THE RULE IS
JOHN CARIBOU
HE BLEW THE WHISTLE ON THE
CIA COVERT TORTURE PROGRAMS AND
WE BROUGHT THEM ON TO ASSESS
THIS NEW WHISTLE-BLOWER.
HOW DO YOU ASSESS THIS ASSESS
THIS WHISTLE-BLOWER?
>> I DO NOT THINK THIS IS A
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
I THINK THIS IS AN ANONYMOUS
SOURCE FOR THE DEMOCRATIC STAFF
IN THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
>> THAT SOUNDS VERY DIFFERENT
FROM A WHISTLE-BLOWER.
WHAT IS A WHISTLE-BLOWER
DISTINCT FROM WHO THIS PERSON
IS?
>> A WHISTLE-BLOWER IS ANYBODY
WHO BRINGS UP WASTE, FRAUD,
ABUSE, THREATS TO PUBLIC HEALTH
OR SAFETY, AND THEY DO THIS
ALMOST ALWAYS WITH A GREAT
PERSONAL COST ATTACHED TO IT.
THIS SO-CALLED WHISTLE-BLOWER AT
THE CIA IS SOMEONE WHO IS ACTING
ANONYMOUSLY AND, REMEMBER, THIS
PERSON IS NOT AN UNDERCOVER CIA
OPERATIVE.
BY ALL ACCOUNTS, THIS IS AN
ANALYST WHO     WHO IS NOT UNDER
ANALYST WHO     WHO IS NOT UNDEO
ANALYST WHO     WHO IS NOT UNDEE
ANALYST WHO     WHO IS NOT UNDE.
YOU CAN'T HIDE THIS PERSON'S
NAME, IDENTITY, JUST TO SAVE HIM
FROM EMBARRASSMENT OR TROUBLE OF
BEING RECOGNIZED OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
IT'S JUST NOT APPROPRIATE.
IF THIS IS A WHISTLE-BLOWER,
NEEDS TO COME FORWARD IN PUBLIC,
TESTIFY IN AN OPEN SESSION, AND
BLOW THAT WHISTLE.
>> WHAT'S INTERESTING IF HE
COMES OUT AND MAKES THESE
ALLEGATIONS AND THE WHITE HOUSE
IMMEDIATELY RELEASES THE
TRANSCRIPT TO END THE STORY.
IN YOUR CASE, YOU MADE
ALLEGATIONS THAT WERE TRUE, IT
TURNED OUT.
AND YOU STILL WENT TO PRISON FOR
SAYING IT.
>> I DID.
I WENT TO PRISON FOR 23 MONTHS.
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT ATTACKED ME
ARE ATTACKING THE PRESIDENT.
ROBERT MUELLER SET IT UP, JOHN
BRENNAN PETITION THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HOLDER TO
CHARGE ME WITH FIVE FELONIES
OF ESPIONAGE, ALL OF IT
DISMISSED.
IRONICALLY IT WAS PETER STRZOK
WHO PUT THE CUFFS ON ME IN 2012.
>> WAIT A SECOND, YOU TOLD THE
TRUTH ABOUT WHAT A FEDERAL
AGENCY WAS DOING WITHOUT THE
KNOWLEDGE OR CONSENT OF
CONGRESS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> OUTSIDE THE DEMOCRATIC
CHANNELS UNDERMINING DEMOCRACY
AND MSNBC AND
>> ACTUALLY ONLY FOX CAME TO MY
DEFENSE.
THAT SOMETHING YOU AND I NEVER
TALKED ABOUT THAT.
MSNBC NEVER CALLED ME A
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
THEY CALLED ME "CIA LEAKER."
SEE AND AN
CNN AFTER A YEAR DECID
CNN AFTER A YEAR DECIT
CNN AFTER A YEAR DECIO
CNN AFTER A YEAR DECIC
CNN AFTER A YEAR DECIL
ME A WHISTLE-BLOWER.
IT'S TOUGH BEING A
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
POLITICAL LINES ARE DRAWN, AND
THAT'S REALLY WHERE THESE THINGS
USUALLY TURN.
WE ARE SEEING THE DEMOCRAT TO
THE SAME THING RIGHT NOW WITH
THIS CIA OFFICER.
THEY ARE TELLING US, IMPOSING
UPON US THEIR NOTION THAT THIS
PERSON IS A WHISTLE-BLOWER AND
HE SIMPLY IS NOT.
>> Tucker: I DON'T THINK THERE
IS ANY CHANCE THIS PERSON IS
GOING TO DO ALMOST TWO YEARS IN
PRISON.
>> NOT A CHANCE.
EVEN HIS ATTORNEY MARK ZAID IS
ONE OF THESE CNN INSIDERS.
HE'S ATTACHED WITH CIA SECURITY
CLEARANCE.
IF YOU ARE REPRESENTED BY MARK
ZAID AND CLAIMING TO BE IT WAS